one of the touchiest subjects that
anyone can mention right now
this was the cause of the blm riots that
burned down the country this was the
cause of so much rancor last year
the george floyd case now the george
floyd
case has gone to trial former officer
derek
chauvin is on trial did he murder
george floyd did he accidentally kill
george floyd did george floyd
die of a drug overdose what is going on
in the trial right now
we are actually getting some breaking
news that apparently the judge just
abruptly excused the jury
is going on recess for the weekend
but someone with greater expertise on
this subject then i can help weigh in
brandon tatum former police officer
co-founder of blexit
and author of beaten black and blue
being a black cop
in an america under siege brandon thank
you for being here
hey thanks for having me on so brandon
what am i supposed to know about this
case
you've got this unique perspective here
uh we we always hear the racial aspect
of the case
we rarely hear the cop aspect of the
case
how does how does it stand and is this
guy going to the clink
well i think that i'm i'm satisfied to
say that this is not going to be tried
based on race there's no charge of hate
crime
involved so chauvin is not going to be
on trial because he was a racist white
man
who killed george floyd and cold blood
that's not going to be what's going to
be heard to the you know the jury is not
going to hear that
that and uh defense and prosecution's
not going to argue that so
the things that we need to know and kind
of like you said in the very beginning
is did the actions of
of officer chauvin cause the death
either intentionally caused the death or
through negligence
caused the death of george floyd and
with the information that has come out
more recently
the defense is really painting a picture
of george floyd being a
drug user habitual uh crime committer
a habitual liar when he's taken into
custody claiming he can't breathe
uh claiming he wants his mom all of
those cues that people were
so upset about they're proving to a
certain degree
that this is normal behavior and that
the police officers may not have been
able to diagnose
his distress based on some of those
factors so
i i've seen some headlines so far about
the witnesses that the defense is
calling and
some of the claims of the drug use and
possible overdoses
how convincing is it you know these are
things that we really
hadn't heard all that much about before
the trial how much is this going to sway
things
yeah i think the jury would be
incredibly convinced that this is not a
you know a man who's changed turning his
life around and he was somehow
under the knee of a police officer
getting killed um for eight minutes
you know this is they're painting the
picture of who george floyd really was
and how police were responding to him
what were they thinking
it kind of you know points to the mental
state of officers and the mental state
of george floyd
when they spoke about him being on drugs
because this is going to be a huge
factor
is did he die from the methamphetamine
and fentanyl that he put
into his system which were above lethal
amounts i think it was three to four
times the
lethal dosage of any of those drugs so
um
that's going to be on trial but the jury
has an opportunity to see his behavior
his mannerisms
the drugs that he used the effect that
it had on him and also the mannerisms of
you know officer chauvin and the other
officers before
he requested them put him on the ground
and claiming that he couldn't breathe
even when he was in the back of the
police car so
them being able to see the full spectrum
the totality of circumstances
i believe it gives them a a more
balanced way to
to move forward in this trial but
brandon i am reliably informed
by the mainstream media that this trial
is not about derek chovan it's not about
what he did
it's not even about george floyd it is a
national reckoning on race and so we
have to ignore all the evidence of the
trial
and we just need to think about slavery
and jim crow
and all redlining you know whatever
anything not to talk about the actual
facts on the ground here
do you think that that narrative is
going to be successful yeah i think the
narrative is going to be successful i i
will say this
right now that no matter what happens in
this trial
there's going to be riots there's going
to be protests there's going to be
burning of buildings
there's going to be people looting and
buying and stealing jordans out of the
store
um as if it had anything to do with
george floyd there's going to be a
narrative that precedes this
you know for the rest of history that is
the goal by the mainstream media
politicians they don't care about george
floyd's life
they don't care about my uh officer
chauvin's life or the other officers on
scene they don't they could care less
this is an opportunity for them to get
money through ratings this is an
opportunity for politicians to get
reelected
by pushing a false narrative of racism
in in this country
and and i hope that people will be able
to see through the mud
and say that you know this has nothing
to do with race
this has everything to do with an
encounter of a police officer
and a man who was high on
methamphetamine and fentanyl that went
tragic
and i hope that people can see through
listen to the trial yourself
it's available online you can go and
watch every day of it
watch the trial listen to the defense
argument listen to the prosecution
listen to the witnesses and then draw a
conclusion
which will be the conclusion of the jury
um don't rely
solely on media input because they're
they're biased
and they have an agenda so much of what
the left is saying
is that you
meaning the white man broadly the you
white man could never
understand what is going on here because
you do not have the lived experience of
a black man in america
so really whatever you think you saw on
video that's not the whole story there
are all these
implicit and subtle things going on and
we hear that
all the time what about the other side
of this though
the cop perspective that i you know i
was never a police officer
i i really don't know what it's like to
be a cop this is an area that you
certainly
have some experience in what is that
dynamic like that maybe civilians don't
quite understand
well it's very incredibly you know
complex to be a police officer
and especially now in america it's
people have no idea
about policing even people who support
the police have no idea about policing
no fault of their own it's impossible to
know unless you're on the street with
the uniform you can smell
you hear the patrol car you get that
fear that adrenaline runs through your
body when it's life and death situations
that you deal with every day
seeing people you know in in very bad
conditions having a notified next-to-can
that the family members are never coming
home
those emotions that adrenaline that
experience can never be replicated can
never be produced in a book
you have to actually be there and i
think that a lot of people have no idea
about policing
which makes them you know prejudice in a
judgment when they see police officers
use force against people or
have to take people's lives by use of
deadly force
and one thing that i think could
mitigate that and i would encourage
everybody
everybody unless you're a convicted
felon and you can't do this but
i i i would like for everybody to try to
attempt to do a ride-along you know when
the
when the kovi is over i call it the kovi
um do a ride along with a police officer
because you'll see firsthand
how they do traffic stops can you see
the race of a person in the car
even in broad daylight when you're
pulling somebody over you know how
do you feel as a citizen standing by in
the passenger seat
while an officer is pursuing somebody
while an officer is engaging
in a combative suspect um how do you
feel and then you can only imagine
what it's like to have to get out of the
car and i'll tell you this real quick
story i remember i took the lady on the
ride along she was a social justice
warrior her child and my child went to
the same daycare
and i said come do a ride along with me
she was so terrified
that she wouldn't even get out of the
car on a traffic stop i'm talking about
a person getting a speeding ticket
she refused to get out of the car she
stayed in the car she was afraid she was
terrified
and at the end of the day i was able to
convince her that see you know nothing
about policing and you may
want to think twice before you misjudge
them this is such an important point
cause i
actually sometimes when people bring up
usually it's
liberals bringing up all these hidden
aspects of
racial and sexual relations i give it a
little bit of credence
in that i think well yeah i mean maybe
there's many experiences that i haven't
had their
culture matters a great deal so okay i'm
sort of interested in that
but shouldn't we have that same humility
when we're talking about cops i mean
cops are doing a very technical job that
you have to train to do
that requires an immense amount of focus
and discipline
just like i would never uh try to tell a
biologist how to do his job i would
never tell
a carpenter how to do his job i might be
interested i might oversee these things
i might try to study up on it but i
wouldn't i wouldn't just start spouting
off
likewise don't you think we need to give
a little bit of grace to cops
yeah you know honestly i think that this
should be a curriculum in
in the grade school is for people to
understand policing in america
and from an impartial basis meaning
having a police officer i remember when
i was young they used to have dare and
all this stuff and teaching people about
a ban of laws and they need to have
police officers come to the classroom
and talk to young children and explain
to them well i'm a resource for you to
call when you call this is what happens
this is my
job so children can grow up
understanding the truth from police
officers and i'll say this because this
is the biggest misconception
and i still don't understand how people
get to this conclusion
is that law enforcement is racist like i
think the
profession of law enforcement is
probably the least racist profession
in america and why do you say this mr
tatum
it's because we are not concerned about
your race
we get exposed to great people of all
races and also
terrible people of all races we are
trained
we are surviving on character
and not race at all and so i wish people
would understand that
also police patrol and jurisdictions
they don't just
log in one day and go to the black
community and harass black people
like this there's a precinct in that
community and you only
you know policing that precinct and if
you police on the north side you would
never interact with these people on the
south side so it's not
some big police department that's
conspiring against the black community
so
i wish that people would would
understand that doing a ride along
listening to police officers actually
speak on these topics
would be the best form of education i
love this education component too
because there was a time not so long ago
in america when students were taught
civics
now students are taught sort of
anti-civics but they're taught their
country is awful and their system of
laws are unjust
but when you're learning about civics
you you
really ought to learn about the whole
country all the way up to
the president and the structure of
government and the constitution
but all the way down to how that system
of justice and laws are enforced all the
way down to the police officers
who are actually doing the day-to-day
work
on the streets it probably would would
increase our understanding and our
healing and our compassion whatever
words that the left uses
that they never seem to really believe
in
now i agree that's the way things should
work do you have any hope
you know you spend a lot of time in
politics obviously you've spent time as
a police officer
do you have any hope that that's
actually what's going to happen or not
so much
well i think in increments you know uh
in
isolated situations i think overall uh
we're doomed
because we we've allowed you know
brian to be become the president of the
united states of america and that his
administration and all of these people
are gonna ram
um unjustifiable legislation down our
throats
and and if you know if we would have
taken that position we should have done
the same thing to them we drug our feet
when we had the house the senate and the
president so with him in place they're
gonna ram some things down our throats
that's that's irreversible however
um individuals like you and i on small
scales can
educate people and inspire them to be
informed on their own
some schools are going to adopt this
principle some universities will adopt
this principle meaning some professors
and with turning point and prageru and
all of these other
organizations that are out doing the
non-profit work
are going to help and i i fail to
mention blexit as well
are going to help to help people wake up
who are willing
you know everybody's not going to want
to learn the truth everybody's not going
to want
to be informed as a free individual but
for those
who want it the opportunities will
present themselves in a greater way in
the future
i i have to say i appreciate your
characteristic bluntness when you say we
are doomed you know it reminds me
of the liberal economist john maynard
keynes
who says in the long run we're all dead
that's true but hopefully
i think you're right i mean there's a
very conservative principle that
gradually you can make incremental
change
especially in your local community and
your family i mean i love that
story you tell about bringing some crazy
social justice warrior that you knew
because of your kid's preschool bringing
her on a ride along because you could
actually show her something
that that really you can't quite do
through a podcast or through a speech
maybe occasionally but
that personal interaction is going to be
really really important and everybody
has the ability to to do that no matter
how crazy things get and i think you're
absolutely right
i think things are going to get a whole
lot crazier brandon where can people
find you the officertatum.com the
officer tatum the
officer tatum.com you can find
everything i do whether it's whether
it's social media whether it's my store
whether it's my website
all of those things will be at that one
spot not a officer tatum there is only
one
there is only the officer tatum uh go
check out brandon there thank you sir i
really appreciate it really helped
i think shed a lot of light on something
where the the left wants to keep
their narrative as the only narrative
brandon
tatum